continuing our conversation from earlier
about cults and scams we have to talk
about Carrie Lake Carrie Lake who lost
her attempt at becoming governor of
Arizona is still talking about suing to
overturn the election at this point I
don't even know if the people hosting
her believe this dribble here is Carrie
Lake on with Tucker Carlson last night
and she is still acting like there's
actually something going on here that
might allow her to become the governor
of Arizona she won't she won't listen to
this we vote for a full month in Arizona
with early ballots and on Election Day
when the Republicans showed up the
election day voting was sabotaged and
that it was not sabotaged a few
tabulators briefly didn't work they were
fixed that's what our case is going to
prove it's a 70-page lawsuit that reads
like a real crime novel yeah it I mean
it it reads like a crime novel in the
sense that it's fiction this was overall
a bizarre interview here's how Tucker
Carlson introduced Kerry Lake and this
is he devoted four and a half minutes to
this which on the one hand isn't a lot
but for a Fox News segment for something
so absurd they often will do two-minute
interviews and this is a four and a half
minute interview we won't watch all of
it don't worry I won't subject you to
that
according to official tallies Kerry Lake
lost her bid to become the next Arizona
governor by just over 17 000 votes
that's a training margin in a big state
now lake is suing the state's election
officials she says many ballots were not
properly counted she also says her
opponent then Secretary of State Katie
Hobbs worked illegally with big Tech to
sounds voters online and for the record
that appears to be true there is not
actually evidence of that lake is also
citing widespread printer failures in
Maricopa County also true she says they
prevented people from voting Maricopa
County claims they didn't stop anyone
from voting but has not responded
further we reached out to Kitty Hawk Now
understand the way they they manipulate
language Maricopa County has said they
did not prevent anyone from voting but
they have not responded further it is
not on them to respond further Kerry
lake has not actually presented evidence
of that these folks I want to say they
don't understand
they certainly pretend at least not to
understand burden of proof it was his
office and got no reply at all Carrie
Lake joins us tonight Kelly thanks so
much for coming on what an important
conversation we're going to have so
Maricopa County is as far as I
understand it does not deny that a huge
number of printers didn't work on
Election Day but they're saying it had
no effect
I don't know what Kerry Lake's going to
say here we're going to check it out in
a moment
um remember
they don't deny it the Republican Party
filed a lawsuit initially over the
broken tabulators once they were
satisfied a few tabulators briefly
didn't work everyone who wanted to vote
voted everything was okay the Republican
Party retracted that lawsuit people are
satisfied other than Kerry Lake
well and it had a huge effect obviously
Tucker our our voters were showing up on
Election Day that was no secret and the
minute the polls opened the wheels fell
off the ballot printers weren't working
there wasn't enough toner in the
printers the tabulators weren't working
it became a debacle and the line started
forming right away some of the lines
three hours four hours five hours and
there's video of people walking out of
line people told us and this is in our
lawsuit that they showed up they
couldn't even find parking because the
parking lots were full and the lines
were long and many people didn't even
get to vote and those who did vote when
they went up to uh you know get the
printer out the printer didn't have
toner in it so the the ballots weren't
dark enough and our voters were showing
up and voting three to one to uh on for
me on Election Day think of that that
none of that is even remotely believable
and there's no evidence for any of it
but listen she's filed a lawsuit so I
guess I guess at some point it'll all
come out right like Mike pillow used to
always say remember pillow we're doing a
class
and yet the information never seems to
make its way out vote for a full month
in Arizona with early back all right and
this is the segment that you already
heard Carrie Lake then appearing on real
America's voice again to give an update
on this lawsuit now again I just don't
know does Carrie Lake really believe
this is going to go anywhere or is it
just a way to raise money because if you
actually look below uh in these tweets
she responds donate to my legal fund
save Arizona fund is this just another
grift to try to make money or does she
genuinely believe this might go anywhere
listen to this update from her we had
three whistleblowers from Maricopa
County reach out and say the system is
flawed seriously flawed the three levels
they have to determine if a signature is
valid or not they were throwing out tens
of thousands of signatures saying they
were scribbles they in no way matched
but somewhere between there and the ball
is being completely tossed out they got
looped back into the system encounted as
if they were fine this is crazy are you
even sometime between
the mismatch on the signature she claims
exists and the ballots being tossed they
were counted as if they were fine
so is the problem that ballots were
counted or weren't carry I guess it's
both and they had no flagging done and
they laid it out how that happened how
somewhere between being flagged as a bad
signature and going into the curing
process which would mean they were cured
sauteed and later cold smoked phone
calls or emails to the actual voter to
see if they wanted to come in and verify
their signature dear God it wasn't
happening there was a disconnect there
and there's a disconnect all right and
part of the disconnect is first the
problem was disenfranchisement people
didn't get to vote now the problem is
too many people voted whose votes
shouldn't actually count here's the real
position right
her supporters weren't allowed to vote
and people who didn't really mean to
vote for Katie Hobbs had their votes
counted for Katie Hobbs but I guess
those would be her supporters right I
mean it doesn't really make any sense if
her supporters weren't allowed to vote
and votes that weren't really for Katie
Hobbs were accounted for Katie Hobbs
those wrongfully counted votes for Katie
Hobbs must have been her voters so they
were allowed to vote except part of the
argument is there wasn't if you don't
know what I'm talking about it's because
it doesn't make any sense every
whistleblowers said that they believed
that a second level manager was pushing
these through these rejected ballots
pushing them through as if they were
approved and we did some calculations
and we believe that up to 135 000
ballots were pushed through that should
not have been pushed through we're
asking a judge to let us take a look at
all of the yeah it's just not going to
happen and again I don't know whether
she believes this crap or whether she
just needs to get her followers to
believe it none of it makes sense
there's no evidence for all of it it's
2020 all over again lawsuit lawsuit
lawsuit they're all thrown out if and
when something is actually granted
they'll say no no no no but you're just
looking at those bogus ballots and just
counting them again we need to actually
throw them out it'll be the same thing
nothing will happen carry Lake loss
Katie Hobbs is going to be the governor
of Arizona that's the bottom line Sorry
to people holding out hope if there are
actually any that somehow carry Lake
will end up Governor it's as likely as
that Trump will end up reinstated from
2020 which I guess some people believe
will happen but it's not going to before
you go if you enjoyed this video and
want to see more please make sure to
subscribe to my YouTube channel you can
click the Subscribe button below or
above or wherever it is on your screen
and if you want to support my work even
more strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description